e aí
eu vou começar a falando de um dia muito
bom recente na nossa história em que
justamente esse dia em que a gente foi
eleito a melhor agritech do brasil na
frança há poucos meses atrás agrotécnica
uma startup voltada para o agronegócio e
isso vende o histórico muito
interessante muito bom porque no último
ano a gente cresceu muito a gente
conquistou muitas coisas a gente já tá
em cinco países a gente tem ampliado
cada vez mais a nossa atuação com novos
produtos e novas áreas e isso tem sido
uma fase muito boa na nossa história só
que quem ver todo isso tudo isso todo
esse sucesso tudo todas essas conquistas
não imagina que a gente nasceu de uma
forma tão humilde com quase nenhum
dinheiro nós eram nos quatro loucos que
estavam tão humilhado sem iniciar alguma
coisa com a nossa
e aí e construir o nosso legado com isso
que a gente simplesmente pediu demissão
e dor de cabeça a gente mergulhou no
vazio a gente pulou do abismo e foi isso
e para quem não reconhece eu sou cara
sentar magrinho jovem e esse foi o nosso
início isso é a área de churrasco da
casa da minha mãe e a gente começou
assim sem nada sem quase nenhum dinheiro
e o que era para ter durado um ano para
gente construir nosso primeiro produtos
acabou durando 4 anos e foram quatro
anos de uma intensa sobrevivência por 14
anos argos quatro anos e foi o tempo da
minha graduação puxa e durante esse
tempo a gente conseguiu sobreviver
porque a gente acabou aprovando alguns
projetos de pesquisa projetos de
invenção e isso acabou dando um fôlego
para nós mas de alguma forma a gente
cruzou esse caminho
e quando a gente está falando de
desenvolver software depende só de você
só de das pessoas que estão interagidos
mas o nosso caso era diferente porque a
gente tinha que desenvolver rápido é
também dia que criar equipamento e isso
custa muito caro e como fazer isso
quando não se tem dinheiro nenhum e a
gente tem que começar de alguma forma
principalmente porque o software
precisava começar junto não tinha como
software começar antes só assim e foi
assim que a gente começou em lavras não
só com um pouco recurso mais uma cidade
de interior na cidade super pequena e a
maioria das pessoas acham que não dá
para empreender no interior porque não
aqui não se tem conexões aqui não se tem
recursos mas dá
e a gente começou e esse o nosso
glorioso protótipo de papelão
e foi assim que a gente começou durante
muitos anos a maioria das pessoas nunca
viram essas fotos porque eu tinha muita
vergonha disso e hoje é o motivo de
muito orgulho a gente começou com que a
gente tinha a gente não esperou por
grandes recursos por nada de outras
pessoas gente começou simplesmente a
fazer a gente sabia nessa época que nada
podia estar na nossa frente a gente tem
que começar e fazer não importava o que
ea gente começou a evoluir disso
a e do papelão a gente passou para
isopor e do isopor a gente passou para
madeira da madeira para o ferro e do
ferro para as ligas metálicas até o
ponto que a gente chegou hoje
é uma evolução imensa no período do
grande que levou muito sacrifício mas
não importava o sacrifício que precisava
ser feito a gente tinha que fazer e a
gente tinha um desejo e direcionamento
para isso
é mas é interessante na história na
nossa história de identificar os
pequenos pontos que mudaram muita coisa
sem que a gente nem sequer imaginar e é
bem um efeito borboleta que você tem um
pequeno evento e muda tudo sem
despretensiosamente eu acho que na vida
de todos aqui isso acontece isso
acontece também na vida das empresas
e quando a gente for incubado em 2011 a
gente foi participou de uma reportagem
de tv e uma das pessoas que assistiram
essa reportagem informou professora da
universidade que por sorte é uma das
maiores pesquisadores de sementes do
mundo ela entendeu a tecnologia que a
gente estava desenvolvendo entendeu que
aquilo poderia perfeitamente ser
aplicado por um universo de semente ela
nos procurou e o fruto disso foi o nosso
primeiro produto que por sinal esse
universo de sementes ainda é um dos
universos mais importantes para a gente
até hoje e quando a gente imaginar que o
nosso primeiro produto e a nascer de uma
simples reportagem de tv
ah e não é só de coisas boas também que
isso acontece né a gente participou de
um evento uma competição de startups e a
gente chegou nessa competição e cada vez
mais a gente achava que ia ser um trunfo
muito grande porque nessa época o foco
principal era web 2.0 o pessoal tava
procurando o próximo facebook e a grande
maioria das empresas estavam focadas só
nisso em construir plataformas online e
a gente era um único empresa nesse nesse
concurso que estava desenvolvendo
realmente tecnologia
e no final com coisas espelho o último
lugar e foi uma decepção gigante e a
gente ia sair de lá derrotado ao extremo
e super chateado mas no público nas
pessoas que estavam lá tinha um cara da
intel
oi e esse cara entendeu o objetivo
entendeu o que a gente estava
desenvolvendo entendeu que a gente tava
trabalhando ele procurou a gente a gente
conversou durante um bom tempo lá depois
do que acabou o evento e na semana
seguinte ele apresentou a gente para em
devo ainda évora é uma hora instituição
mundial que apoia e o imperador
empreendedorismo e por causa disso a
gente pode participar de um programa
super bacana da da ideia chamada skype
mas a gente teve acesso a mentores
fantásticos a pessoas que já tinham
cruzado esse abismo que já tinham
cruzado esse caminho que a gente estava
cruzando ou seja a gente acabou
conquistando muito mais do que a gente
queria no início e essa forma vitória
gigantesca só que passou um tempinho
depois ainda era apresentou a gente para
incide que foi o primeiro fundo que
investiu a gente nós em 2014
bom então a gente vê que até de uma
derrota a gente consegue colher frutos
positivos também nesse caso um grande
fruto
é mas falando um pouco sobre a história
das empresas geralmente a gente vê algo
como que tá aqui projetado a gente vê
essa linha de tempo que é tão bonita
esteticamente tão bacana de ver a linha
cruzando os anos os produtos nascendo o
mercado sendo conquistados e por mais
que esteja bonito de ver algo assim isso
não condiz com a história de uma startup
eu me recuso achar que alguma startup
vive essa coisa bela de contos de fada
porque na verdade o dia a dia de uma
startup é isso
e são altos e baixos completamente
vertiginosos e imprevisíveis gente não
consegue prever absolutamente nada a
gente tem quedas a gente levanta a gente
vive situações completamente aleatórias
e é um caos constante só que o ser
humano ele não nasceu para viver nesse
universo o ser humano gosta de
previsibilidade de segurança então
empreender é um criar essa tendência do
ser humano e é uma coisa que a gente tem
que se adaptar ou a gente não vai viver
nesse universo de empreendedorismo
dentro desse universo isso não acaba os
autos se tornam cada vez mais altos e os
baixos se tornam cada vez mais baixa
então isso você com convive o resto da
sua vida com isso e a ok a gente já
aprendi a conviver com isso só que
em poucas pessoas e isso cai muito nesse
universo de porque empreender para que
tá vivendo nesse universo eu acho que
uma coisa que me ajudou muito nessas
idas e vindas são grande amigo que teve
sempre presente do meu lado que foi o
álcool mas isso cai muito no assunto
interessante que envolve uma mística por
trás que é porque empreender muitas
pessoas se perguntam por isso e na
maioria das vezes eu escuto muito que o
motivo principal que chama atenção das
pessoas pelo empreendedorismo é o
dinheiro
é só que as pessoas que empreendem pelo
dinheiro só as primeiras que desistem
porque olha nossa história a gente levou
quatro anos para lançar o primeiro
produto a gente viveu sem dinheiro
durante várias fases e eu tenho certeza
que em todo empreendedor vive isso vive
essa realidade de estar sem dinheiro
ocasionalmente então para para você
chegar ganhar algum dinheiro isso é uma
consequência lá no final não é no início
não é pelo dinheiro
e eu uso muito também que é pelo status
pelo nome pela representatividade e na
verdade é o oposto você tá frente de uma
startup você tá empreendendo logo não
existe difícil constante de humildade
porque você tem que fazer o subitamente
tudo você se precisar você tem que
varrer o chão e precisar você vai fazer
o café se precisar você vai para o
hospital tomar ponto porque se
desengonçado e cortou o dedo produzir no
equipamento eu você vai fazer de tudo
que for preciso do ponto mais baixo ao
ponto mais alto só que acima de tudo é a
humildade extrema de reconhecer que nada
do sucesso que ali que foi gerado é seu
são das pessoas que estão envolvidas ali
no dia a dia
e então também não é pelo status e eu
acho que trazer um exemplo agora da
minha história de uma forma como eu eu
me coloco dentro desse universo e que eu
justifico muito para mim o que que é
empreender eu vou trazer um exemplo de
um episódio que aconteceu comigo em 2017
e eu tinha uma reunião muito importante
para eu ir e eu sofri um acidente
a maioria das pessoas nesse tipo de
situação e a entrar em choque e ia
querer rever alguma coisa na vida
e eu não tive nada eu alguns roxos eu
sair desse acidente e eu fui para minha
reunião
a maioria das pessoas iriam rever
posicionamentos da vida eu precisei de 0
segundos para rever a única coisa que
passou na minha cabeça foi entendeu mas
depois do acidente não tive nada ótimo
vão para reunião eu precisava estar lá a
empresa precisava disso eu precisava
disso e tá ok eu acho que isso aqui é um
testemunho de fé só que demonstra a
paixão se o que demonstra que nada que
entra no caminho não vai ser superado
não existe obstáculo que não vai ficar
para trás e só que representa não a
minha história mas a história da maioria
das pessoas que empreendem e hoje a
gente tem essa família bonita a gente já
conquistou muita coisa e a gente tem uma
história muito única estou extremamente
feliz
eu não gostaria de estar em nenhum outro
local e eu tenho certeza que dessa
história única ainda a gente vai ter
muitos capítulos obrigado pessoal ó
e aí
[Aplausos]